It's time now to practice some very
useful phrases. I'll say them first.
You repeat, I will learn
together. That's begin.
This is radio lab today. Translation.
It's time to begin.
We'll have eight experiments
in translation. Transcreation
lesson number one. The
best poem was by my mother.
[inaudible] people would
be my mom. No, you try it.
Hello. Hi there. Hi. Is
that dog? Yes. Oh boy.
So, uh, this episode was inspired
by a guy named Doug Doug Hofstadter,
professor of cognitive science,
Indiana University Bloomington. Uh,
you may know him as the guy
who wrote Godel Escher Bach,
which was a hugely influential
book in certain circles, uh,
published in I think 1979 but we
actually got interested in him. Uh,
thanks to our producer Lynn Levy
because of an obsession of his,
which predates that 16, I was 16,
the year 1961.
I was taking a French literature class
on one day. I came across this poem,
a tiny little poem that kind of sat
right in the middle of the page,
like a long thin sausage vertical. Ah,
three syllables per line.
So it was super skinny and 28 lines
long and long and it was delightful.
It was very cute and funny.
I fell in love with a poem
immediately and memorized that.
I still know it by heart. The
poem is basically a Getwell card.
It was written by this guy, Clemon morrow,
who was a poet in the early 15
hundreds the court of a queen.
And he wrote the poem for
a, this Queen's daughter.
She was seven or eight and she had gotten
sick of flu or something and this poem
was supposed to cheer her up and,
and her thought was very sweet.
Could you say it in French? Let's just
hear it first. Yeah. Okay. It's called,
uh, Yoon dumb. Was that in
Malad to a sick demos El,
so to speak, like young
lady, a sick young lady, Mami
[inaudible], Lucy [inaudible], [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] at the taboo. Shh.
[inaudible] Emoji comfy too. You see,
you do your Tomala cooler fat
two pound a paradol on bone.
Poor Joe to Diwan Asante Burn Armenian.
Oh my God. You must have gotten so
many chicks when you were six, seven.
That was really crazy.
Exactly the opposite. I was,
I was a wish. Okay, so he reads the poem,
files it away deep in the corner of
his mind. Fast forward about 20 years,
he publishes his first book.
He becomes very popular and the publisher
decides to have it translate into a
number of languages, including French.
And that process, which took years,
it put me into the frame
of mind of thinking,
what kinds of crazy things can happen
when you crazy texts and all of a sudden
one day that poem popped
into his mind and I said, ah,
there's a challenge. Let's try to
do this. And when you say challenge,
like what was it? What is it?
What is the challenge? Okay,
what I meant was to say, here's the
thing. He says, you got this poem.
[inaudible] if you just
focus on the words,
it's basically just this guy talking to
a younger girl saying, hello my dear.
I'm sorry you're sick.
Being sick is like prison.
I Claremont wish you to open your doors,
get out into the world clean loaned of
women. Get out of bed, eat some jam.
If you too, so you don't look so
pale, loose your plump shade pill dog,
you know, it's sort of like get better.
Here's to your good health due
to the [inaudible], I mean young,
but just saying those words in English
misses the whole spirit of the poem,
the tone, the lightheartedness.
And, and this is key for Doug.
It also ignores the poems form.
It's wonderfully catchy little
sausage shape on the page.
The fact that the lines rhyme,
you know, a, B, B, c, c, d,
and uh, the first line [inaudible]
is identical to the last line.
I mean, young sorta has
the feel of a palindrome.
It has the poet's name in the middle of
the poem. [inaudible] oh, and I forgot,
did I say three syllables per law?
You didn't that, yeah, of course.
Three syllables per line. I mean, that's
crucial. And then also 28 lines long.
So all of those things added up to a
set of constraints you might say on me.
So Doug sat down and got to work and uh,
quickly became embroiled
in the question of like,
how do you translate this poem? You know,
along the way he even began to make
a little grids of possibilities for
different lines of the poem. For example,
who yawned at the top Bush like this
line that basically says don't wallow in
bed. I had a lot of possibilities
and I'll just read you the uh,
little diagonal display here.
Instead of spurting blood in bed
instead of burping in your bed,
instead of bursting out in bed instead
of lurking in Europe instead of hurtling
out of instead of hurting there and
instead of squirming and your instead of
slurping slop and instead of burning up
in bed instead of turning blue in bed on
and on. And I came up with, you want
me to read my first translation please?
My sweet dear. I sent you
all the best. You're forced.
Rest is like jail, so don't
ale very long. Just get strong.
Go outside, take a ride,
do it quick. Stay not sick.
Ban Your ache for my sake. Buttered
bread while in bed. Makes a mess.
So unless you would choose that bad news,
I suggest that you'd best soon
arise so your eyes will not glaze.
Douglass. Praise health. Be
Near my sweet dear. So whoa.
So claymores now Douglas clean
all became Douglas and I,
I the word John Jam became bread though.
Buttered to bread. Buttered bread.
Buttered bread. Yes. Well I just
figure jam and Jelly. They are words,
but the words represent concepts and
the concept have a kind of a halo around
them. I mean when you talk about Jelly,
you're implicitly talking about bread
and things that you spread it on.
Oh, how interesting. People like
just stick their fingers in Jelly.
No bread needed. Okay. Okay, fair enough.
Feeling like he hadn't quite nailed it.
Doug sent the poem to one of the guys
that translated his first book into
French. Yeah. A guy named oddly enough,
Bob French and Bob was and I said,
hey Bob, can you do it?
And uh, Bob said, wow,
give it a try. Fairest friend
letting me send my embrace.
Quit this place. It's dark
holes and dank walls in soft,
still regain health dress and
flea off with me. Clement,
who calls for you,
very different in tone and
really quite marvelous.
He got the a pale face in there. He got
the gym claimant's name in the middle,
but at the same time it
didn't have the lightness.
The tone is much more ancient, which you
could argue, well it's an ancient poem,
but Doug says, no, no, no, there's a
big a problem that was 30 lines long.
So extra long and 28
was a sacrosanct number.
That's just two lines
though. No, no, no, no, no.
Klemow Maho wrote a three syllable poem
of 28 lines that rhymed wonderfully.
And the essence of his poem
was a form rather than a,
uh, than a message that is, the message
was get well, which is pretty simple.
But Doug would argue no, it was the form.
That's what made the
thing funny and charming.
And so the question for him was who
could get the feel but nail the form?
To make a long story short, he ended up
sending the poem out to like 60 people,
doctoral students, whom I,
sweet. I entreat one regard,
Otis hard dear recluse
colleagues, friends chickadee.
I decree a fine day.
Even got his wife to do one dart away
from your cage and engage in brave flight
so you might flee the croup. That was
all bird themed. Hope you swoop into ham,
apple jam and French bridge. You go
running around from town to town saying,
hey, I got a little poem.
Anybody want to [inaudible]
I am a person of binges.
This began a binge.
She might say in that binge ended up
becoming a 700 page book filled with
translations of this poem. Go ahead and
read the last one. Now this is the bell,
right? Right. No, this
is not the best one.
This is just that one and I'll
stop it. Okay, here we go. Okay.
Okay. This is also one of his, but like
the 20th one he did POW petite Gal.
So sweet hug from duck, some
dumb bug dragged you down.
Zap that fram feel the urge
bugs to purge from the scourge.
You'll emerge in a Trice sound
advice from ham dunk slash. Clem.
So smash flu come you who come
you who lived at you sheets.
S eschew sweet. Let's Chew Papa Tart.
Make your heart palpitate. Klemm's
mandate. Sure. Hope God cures your body.
Head to feet. Pound
there, hub got your mind
set in the red. It's humorous,
although not the best. He says,
I do want to get to my
mother's translation speakers.
My mother's was somehow, I'm
going to have to look it up here.
Where it was. It was that this
book is long and complicated than
this one from his mom. He says came
along years after he started. Sure it is,
and he thinks that might be the winter
high. Twits get well, hospitals,
prison and prisons. Hell,
get well. Flea yourself.
Clements orders in a nutshell.
Go pig out. Open wide your mouth.
Keep those sweetmeats going south. Unless
you're hail, you'll turn Pale loose.
Ooh, la La. That wiggles your tail.
God restore good health to you.
My little flower.
Oh, that's cool.
I noticed that she doesn't begin the
poem and end the poem with the same line.
She doesn't have 28 lines. She
has maybe about 16 lines. Uh,
she doesn't pay any attention
to syllable counts. I did.
My first reaction was, oh
mom, no mom, come on, come on.
I didn't pay any attention to
the form and, and she said,
I did what I wanted to do. This is my
feeling, you know, that's what I did.
And actually, you know,
I have to say it has
stood the test of time.
It has some kind of pizazz
that no other one ever had.
But if she didn't respect the
form, he didn't do the syllable.
She didn't rhyme it the way it's supposed
to rhyme. She didn't give you 28 line.
She even like have that practically set
a translation then or is that just a
mom? I left a hundred flowers bloom.
As I got more and more deeply into this
poem and my philosophy started to become
Chairman Mao's statement, let 100
flowers bloom. In other words,
you can look at it from so many angles
and each new angle enriches it and makes
it more fun.
But you can't read a hundred versions of
every poem that you want to read. Okay?
Okay. I agree. You're right. It
does make me question though.
The rules of engagement in a way.
There are no rules. There are no rules.
It's all informal. Okay?
But there's jam in one of the translations
and ham in the other and they're
like,
they're factually different foods and
substances somehow like the facts of the
poem shouldn't be negotiable should
they? What is, what do you mean by fact?
I mean, the fact about the poem is that
it was written by somebody in French.
It's not in French anymore. Now,
here's what Jared I think
was really wondering is, uh,
the mission we thought was,
what was he saying?
Not what do we make of what he's saying?
What are the flavors of what he's saying?
What are the variants of what
he's saying beyond that? Like,
isn't the expectation that you as
a translator are giving me him?
Like, hey this,
this man has lost to time and now
suddenly I get to experience him,
but if a hundred flowers are blooming,
that somehow feels like
I'm not getting him at all.
Obviously you're getting to the
question of what is translation and Ah,
can it be done? My,
my feeling is that even though these
translations that we've heard are all very
different, they all show something about
Clayman Moho Doug's basic point is that
like any person is kind of a universe,
they're too big to
comprehend in their entirety.
And so any translation of say,
a poem or whatever is only going to
get you a tiny piece of that person.
A tiny refraction. I mean, look, we
have one photograph of Fredrick Chopin
[inaudible]
one photograph, and in that
picture he says, ah, he scowling.
What did Fredrick Chopin really look
like? What was his smile? You know,
you look at a photograph
of Chopin and you say, oh,
this is what Chopin looked like. Well,
no, Chopin looked like many things.
Even the very day that
that photograph was taken,
he had thousands of different
expressions on his face.
But then what about a year earlier
or 10 years earlier? I mean,
knowing Chopin is a very complex
thing. It's not one thing.
It's a millions of different
things that we're United by analogy
[inaudible]
into something that we
refer to as one thing.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
we should say we looked into it and there
are actually two pictures of Chopin,
but he's kind of scowling and both are,
you can't really tell him the second
one to disintegrate. No smiles.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
quote on McDonnell CAFO e. E. R.
You [inaudible] Miss,
you couldn't be any, no.
E e a Yo
[inaudible] farm bet.
[inaudible] [inaudible] e. R. E. R.